donald trump is doubling down by the way
he is getting more and more provocative
by the day trump is now not only
endorsing the republicans who run
against the squishes he's now even
endorsing some democrats
trump is endorsing dan goldman who's
running for congress in new york
he says lawyer dan goldman is running
for congress new york's 10th it's my
great honor to strongly endorse him
i do this not because of the fact that
he headed up the impeachment committee
and lost
but because he was honorable fair and
highly intelligent while it was my honor
to beat him and beat him badly dan
goldman has a wonderful future ahead
he'll be very compassionate and
compromising to those within the
republican party
and will do everything possible to make
sure they have a fair chance at winning
against the radical left democrats who
he knows are destroying our country i
would like to thank dan for fighting so
hard for america and for working so
tirelessly to stop trump
he was not easy to beat but winning
against him made me realize just how
very talented i am
this is why he's going to be the nominee
guys
this is why i know i know there are
other candidates
there are other candidates who are doing
a good job
in their current roles
and who could very possibly do a good
job as president
and who very possibly at least in terms
of
public policy maybe they could do a
better job than trump i don't know i'm
not saying they could i'm saying it's
possible
you think about
ron desantis in florida you think about
ted
the
cruz
he's probably the leading senate
candidate for president you've got
desantis for sure the leading governor
candidate for president there are others
too
but this guy if this guy wants it
this guy's going to get it
not only because he's leading 40 points
in the polls not only because the feds
raided his house galvanizing support for
him on the right but he's just
so funny he's so entertaining
and i
think not for us the people who tune
into this show are
high information
very very politically involved
interested people okay by definition i'm
not flattering you if you're listening
to this show means you're consuming
political content
you're consuming it in a kind of
nitty-gritty fairly high-level way
that does not characterize most of the
country
no knock on most of the country most of
the country has other things to do
they're just not interested they have
other interests
and i think for most people
we're not tuning in to the latest who
did liz cheney beat this person and did
this what did steve bannon say about
this person and
for your regular guy who just tunes in
every so often
trump is freaking hilarious he did a
good job as president he's got universal
name recognition and he keeps you
entertained and in every presidential
contest
certainly of my lifetime but going back
much further i think the more
charismatic entertaining candidate won
trump obviously 2016
obama 2012 and 2008 bush 04 and 2000 oh
my gosh bush was running against
thurston howell iii
certainly much more entertaining clinton
against dole clinton against bush
the first
reagan against mondale and carter reagan
against bush in the
primaries on and on and on
and trump is that guy it's not just dan
goldman i'm going to read the other one
too he just trump just endorsed carolyn
maloney carolyn maloney is one of the
leading democrats in the house she's
been there for a long time
trump says a vote for
i can't even get through it a vote for
carolyn maloney in new york 12 is a vote
for the future
she is a kind and wonderful person who
has always said terrific things about me
and will support me no matter what i do
just as i supported her very early on
she begged for a check with no quid pro
quo and i gave it to her in fact i gave
her many
on the other hand jerry nadler is
likewise a hard-driving man of the
people whose energy and attention to
detail is unlike anyone else in congress
he is high-energy sharp quick-witted and
bright
you can't go wrong with either but
carolyn maloney is the better man
she will lead our country into a very
green and prosperous future carolyn has
my complete and total endorsement
she will never let our conservative
movement down
it's a work of art and i will never
forgive jack dorsey for kicking that man
off of twitter and depriving us of that
for a year
until he got truth socialite but now at
least you can kind of see it when people
repost it on twitter
i will i will never that is so funny
because we know that trump despises
carol and maloney and especially jerry
nadler he's been brutal to jerry nadler
he calls him fat jerry
it's so he's so mean to these people and
then he realizes if he endorses them
that's bad for them and so he does it in
this absolutely
hilarious way
and that's that
the test the real final test of trump
2024 is going to be the midterm
elections it's why
at least the people around him
are urging him to wait until after the
midterms to declare
i think probably that's what he's going
to do
liz cheney's loss is a big win for trump
had had liz cheney won
had adam kinzinger been able to even run
for re-election
any of these people if the anti-trump
house republicans had won
trump would be seriously weakened going
into 2024
but they're almost all losing
so that is a big big boost for
trump and that's a big knock to the
other republicans who many of whom are
great people and would make great
presidents but that's a real knock to
them who are seeking the highest office
in the land all these republican
politicians right now go to
goodranchers.com
knowles regardless of what the biden
administration defines as a recession
americans are worried they're feeling it
food and gas prices are higher than i've
ever seen in my lifetime that is why i
am so grateful
for my favorite meat delivery service
good ranchers good ranchers offers an
inflation-proof subscription model that
lets you lock in your price the day you
subscribe i don't know how this works i
hope good ranchers can stay in business
this is such a good deal
you you subscribe right now you can
either buy a box of meat
absolutely top quality meat you just buy
a one-off box and you enjoy it or you
can subscribe and for the whole life of
your subscription it will never go up
do it right now this is the most insane
deal i've ever seen goodranchews.com
knowles use code knowles at checkout you
get 30 bucks off plus free shipping lock
in that price recession proof your meals
for life inflation proof your meals for
life you'll be automatically entered to
win 30 minutes by the way of all access
with me on september 30th if you do that
this offer ends august 31st we're
calling it a meet and greet go to
goodranchers.com and always use code
knowles at checkout
i'm glad you like that clip now whoop
hold up yeah we got a million subscribed
we have over a million subscribers now
that's great it's not good enough we got
to keep pushing
we need a billion subscribers
we're only going to do that if you ring
that bell right now
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you